the Joe Rogan experience did you always
have that style no I didn't when did you
develop that what once we started
working on our Cypress Hill demos mugs
came to me and said hey man you got to
do something
got to do something different otherwise
you're gonna write for sin cos sin had a
good voice his [ __ ] was locked in my
voice I was rapping in a voice similar
to the one I'm talking and although the
rhymes were good it didn't cut through
on the style like on you know on the
beats it just sounded like you know some
regular [ __ ] so you know I don't want to
be someone's writer you know I wanted to
write for myself so you know there was a
guy that we used to listen to coming up
was name was RAM LZ he was on this
record called wild style and he was in
the movie he was this rapper who was
very obscure but he was an artist too
you know like a graffiti artist but then
also an artist artist you know but he
was also a rapper and what he would do
is he'd rap in a regular style like his
talking voice this is the brother they
called the RAM well he had a deep voice
like that and then he would flip right
in the middle
take it up town to Cypress Hill with the
shotgun bow like that and you know we
were always freaking out on that he had
two styles so I tried throwing my voice
in that sort of similar style and it
ended up sticking I didn't really like I
didn't think anybody was gonna like it I
thought get the [ __ ] out of here with
that but they ended up liking it and I
think the first song that came about in
that style was the song real estate off
our first album it's uh you know that
was where I tried it the first time they
liked it so then kill a man came next
and I tried that song and that's down
and hand on the pump and it just became
a flow after that and I really did not
feel it at first I was like [ __ ] I can't
believe they got me rapping in this
voice and it took it took a minute to
get used to that you know like doing it
live because you know I had a tendency
we as as rappers you know that don't
know
cuz there's no school for this unless
you have somebody who's done it and they
teach you okay this is what the get-down
is and we didn't have that really it was
all hands-on learning
ie no for the first few years man I was
trying to do the voice and I'd end up
you know getting overhyped because the
crowd is hype and I'd start yelling the
verses instead of like wrapping them
like on the record I'd throw my voice
out my voice would get scratchy I'd be
sounding like Busta Rhymes and [ __ ] you
know and it took me five years to
actually harness how to actually do the
shows with this voice and I had to go to
this opera singer coach really the name
was something Elizabeth Sabine or
something like that she trained a lot of
folks but she she her [ __ ] was like to
teach you the operatic way of singing
which is from the diaphragm tighten the
stomach take little breaths but those
little breaths make your lungs expand
you know a lot and it's less projection
from your throat and more from the
bottom and she taught me that technique
and I never went horse again after that
I like with you know people often
compliment me on you know sounding so
close to how the records are there's
once in a while where I might get
excited and start saying it louder than
it might be but I'm always sort of right
there and I got it you know I got to
give all props to her cuz if she hadn't
showed me that technique I'd probably
still be yelling and screaming my [ __ ]
out [ __ ] up my voice that brings up
an interesting point is this her yeah
way let me hear citko we can't play this
and she was and she was the opera singer
at one time Wow but she went on to teach
people the technique no kidding man that
is wild see because if you try to keep
your breath and sustain a long note like
that from your chest you won't sustain
that note long enough but if you tighten
doing it from your diaphragm yeah if you
tighten it's almost like you're gonna
take a [ __ ]
[Music]
Oh instead of from the throat that makes
sense yeah you know like it it allows
you it allows your lungs to expand while
you're breathing
mmm through from your diaphragm so
that's what she taught a lot of singers
and it's a another method is to cheat
the word like pronounce it you know like
you're kind of like it's it's like what
these mumble rappers do when they they
pronounce the word and they kind of
mumble it and they sort of cheat it you
know what the word is but they didn't
pronounce it all the way right so so in
other words if she's gonna you were
gonna sing the line come he'd come with
me so it sounds a little bit cleaner
he'd say gum with me but in the way you
would say it is more with a G but it's
so talked in that you hear come with me
and it's just a cheating way of saying
it to get the line a little bit cleaner
and in [ __ ] uh you know in the breath
and she taught me all that [ __ ] and and
it worked for rap I didn't know if it
would because I mean it was it's she
primarily taught singers I was probably
the first rapper that she taught this
technique to and it stuck how'd you find
her um what am one of my friends had
heard of her you know because that mean
in the in the industry we you know
become friends with other you know your
peers and stuff like that and you know I
knew a couple singers and they'd they
they were you know noting my problem is
just you know screaming my verses and
coming back with the raspy voice so they
were like here why don't you try this
person right here this person taught or
or gave this technique to so-and-so and
it was another singer I can't remember
but um I thought well you know what have
I got to lose I mean if it doesn't work
it doesn't work but maybe I learned
something from it that I could use
somewhere else right and [ __ ] she she
taught me the the warm-up
she taught me uh you know the certain
words that you can cheat to you know for
for certain breath control purposes
because the way you pronounce certain
things you know sort of add to
and just that the tightening of the
diaphragm man like if I hadn't learned
that it would have took me a lot longer
to do the shows the way that I can do
them now
so do you warm up before shows I don't
necessarily need to like from the first
song on my voice like gets in like the
first few bars it warms up right then in
there and it's not really like singing
where I got a sustained notes and stuff
like that so I don't have to do those
same kind of warm-ups if I was gonna
sing some [ __ ] yes I would definitely
have to get my you know get the pitch
right and the throat warmed up to to do
those different you know melodies or
whatever the hell but fortunately I
don't sing
[Applause]